[Music]
foreign
has been a 50-year vision it's
unprecedented in Regional Australia we
first wanted to expand something to
really show and expose all of our life's
work in various exotic Pursuits in
agribusiness from Sandalwood through the
pearls and a whole range of other things
to execute this and to display this to
the general public we decided we needed
a farm showcase so we set about building
what we call today the dam the site had
an original Randall shed and around that
we support it was a massive amount of
rock work from there we decided to
extend that Rand Bill shed and we simply
put a second shed of this barn style 30
meters to the east of the original shed
and we said about over a decade filling
it in and it was going great it was it
was a fantastic project
we just forgot to tell the Shire about
it
at some point with my draft person Sue
Parker from Denmark I realized I was out
of my depth I was struggling and I
started doing choir uh who could help me
with this and the the forgione family
Rob forgione's name came up on a number
of occasions from different people who
highly recommended Rob we mapped out
what their Vision was their their
short-term plan and long-term plan part
of our job was to master plan this and
we are currently still Master planning
but with the building that we've got to
date that's been finished has been a
collaboration of engaging all the
Consultants the necessary people
required to get this through Council
that was the biggest hurdle for us
putting together something expand it and
let the local Council and the community
understand what the vision was so that
took a fair bit of work to do and
convert obviously taking the existing to
where it is now because I'd started
building a decade before or a lot of the
compliant issues that I thought I'd
built compliant were no longer the case
with the changing circumstances so the
building was a Minefield of problems and
it required both diplomacy and innate
capacity to understand from you know
lifetime experience that CBD and Rob has
have had to deal with bureaucracy how to
deal with all the various regulations
and bring this building together when we
first started this project it was a
complete and empty shell and obviously
the birkbeck family had an amazing
Vision that they wanted to retain
throughout the entire process
understanding their Vision was a
critical part for us and with an empty
shell means you can have endless
possibilities for us it was making sure
we took the time to listen to our client
and understand what they actually wanted
to achieve being on a large working farm
that meant we couldn't go Ultra Modern
we couldn't take away from the natural
landscape and the natural beauty so for
us it was about maintaining what the
actual environment has to offer and what
we can actually create inside this space
so we took As Much from the natural
environment as we could we found natural
Mari trees and turned them into
beautiful columns we use the birkbeck
family's old Pearl Company spread it
through the concrete floors to make it
something unique and special to them
with a narrative behind it for us it was
also about flow and Direction inside
this facility to make it actually viable
and operational when they didn't have
too many staff and it wasn't too busy
they could still operate this entire
facility with just a handful of staff so
when it came down to it it was all about
the correct Furniture selections the
correct placement even when we went all
the way into the finer details we made
sure we positioned the fireplaces the
log storage units and everything in
between as best as we could to make sure
we've guided the flow of traffic inside
this building as much as we could the
family had existing Stone existing
Timber so basically we created that and
wrapped that around the building with
the use of different materials liaising
with these landscape people helping them
create the landscape and with this
landscape designers put the soft
landscape together worked really well
and again what you see today is a
testament to everybody's involvement it
was interesting to finish the building I
remember we went to the Western
Government for a grant and I asked Rob
for CBD for a reference and at that
point he he stated that the the dam was
one of the most exciting projects he'd
ever been involved with and I have to
say over a lifetime of my work it's one
of the most exciting things I've ever
built
and it's just so satisfying now with
that first year of operation now I look
back we've been going for about 15
months first 12 months we had 60 000
visitors this year we expect about 100
000 visitors
but to a person they walk into this
building and they're Blown Away